so there has been a development i now
need to sign 250 000 times to make sure
that every copy of the anthropocene
reviewed books first printing is signed
i'm going to do that i look forward to
the challenge
thank you for pre-ordering good morning
hicks tuesday so not to sound like a
hipster youtube user or anything but
most of the channels i watch on youtube
do not like
regularly hit the trending page like my
very favorite youtube channel is dr
benji fm
in which a guy named ben plays the video
game football manager imagining a
vast universe in which this fictional
team called afc thames makes their way
through the ranks of english football
it's also a profound window into how
fandom works but mostly i just
root for the red pixels on the screen
another channel i love
curious tangents in which host travis
gilbert models inquiry-based learning by
following curious tangents and seeing
where they lead
like in a recent video he explores what
kinds of stress can actually be
productive for humans and what kinds are
merely deliterious that's one of those
words that i know how to spell
but i don't know how to say anyway then
in another video he'll explore like the
history of dragons it's
wonderful so a chunk of the ad revenue
here at vog brothers goes to sponsoring
educational video projects and i often
discover new favorite channels in that
process like one recent grantee is
soph's notes which is very hard for me
to pronounce soph's videos are hilarious
like whether they're about why i always
have room for dessert or the science
behind hangovers or
which planet would be the most fun to
party on but they're also
deeply informational and because of the
way the information is presented i
remember more of it so i watched them
for fun but then at the end i'm always
like ah
man they got me i learned something
another channel that recently got a
vlogbrothers grant is
this glorious clockwork which features
beautiful animations about biochemistry
like this video is about atp
synthase and i didn't even know i was
interested in biochemistry but it turns
out that i
am myself just a complicated series of
chemical reactions and i would like to
better
understand those reactions i am also a
massive
massive fan of karen puzzles a jigsaw
puzzle youtube channel created by karen
cavett who's been a part of
nerdfighteria since 2007.
it's just so beautifully shot and even
though i don't have any capacity to do
jigsaw puzzles it's
so satisfying to watch them get
completed
speaking of long time nerdfighters my
producing partner rosianna halse rojas
just celebrated her 15th anniversary on
youtube meaning that she has now been
making videos for more than
half of her life i love all of
rosianna's videos but i'm especially
fond of her travel vlogs where through
unhurried editing you can follow her as
she for instance
bicycles across england lastly its
radish time has been uploading video
postcards in 2021 and they are stunning
and poetic and
brilliantly edited and unlike anything i
have seen on youtube before and i love
them
so much i think every year during the
project for awesome i discover new
channels to follow and love as people
make videos
about their favorite charities by the
way there is still time to make a
project for awesome video they have to
be submitted
by wednesday at noon eastern time more
info below like it says on my 2021
vision board let's have a beautifully
foolish project for awesome this year
hank even after 14 years on youtube i'm
still astonished by the creativity in
our community like last week a
nerdfighter named julia created an
animated video called
lo-fi lang sein beats to sign your name
000 times to i think i'm just going to
leave you with a little of that today
i'll see you on friday for the project
for awesome
[Music]
you